My name is Tom Crampton. I'm based out of
Hong Kong. I run social media strategy for
Ogilvy and I'm a blogger. And the question
of whether the political problems or the economical
problems are going to be the biggest ones
going ahead. I have to say that I hope it
is economic problems. If the political problems
are the biggest problems facing East Asia,
these problems are so dangerous and detractable,
that I hate to think what they will be. And
I think what we see right now in the state
of the economic crisis, we might be seeing
the green shoots of recovery. But it's certainly
nothing on the scale as what would happen
it we were to have an outbreak of conflict
on the Korean peninsula or any of the other
major security issues or problem in Scratnese
which would have not just a consequence among
a couple of countries but of a global importance.
So I hope that there are no economic, fewer
economic and fewer political problems, but
I think that the danger is if they are political
ones.